foreign
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on uh
hopefully everything works is everything
working like the microphone and
everything because I was moving some
[__] around so yeah so we got a new
camera coming too I see an image here
let me see if it got audio I mean I
think it's on it looks like it's on and
nobody says no sound yeah yeah okay just
worried about it because you know how it
you breathe on something and it kind of
like turns itself off you know how it
does around here yeah I bought a new
camera today
it's an action cam yeah it's like a
Chinese copy of a GoPro it's it's a
pretty good one though
uh it's called a
a brave seven let's go
got pretty good reviews it's half the
cup price of a GoPro but it's similar
performance for what we're looking for
we can use it as a webcam here it's 4K
we can use it as webcam here and we can
do it for our other [__] um efforts
that we're doing you guys know what I'm
talking about and uh it gets the action
camera if it's like it you know it's
like the size of a damn Ice Cube you can
flip it around it's got
it's got screens on both sides
but uh
when we use it as a webcam we're
probably gonna have to uh run a couple
of test screens we can do it on off
hours
yeah for the show make sure everything's
running good uh figure out how to use it
so just giving you a heads up that
some of the some of the visuals are
going to change make it a little bit
better well hopefully we'll see yeah if
everything works out good
I might get another one so we'll have
two maybe three they're not that
expensive 150 you know 160. yeah that's
not bad for that for what you get I mean
it seems and it seems like it was well
reviewed yeah but uh but yeah and then
uh what else murder Hornets in there
tell me to get my [__] together dude I
just had to return a bra
I don't [__] understand a man's pain
well he well he always is he insists on
doing everything like literally five
minutes before the show starts and he's
always like the [__] too
which makes it seem like I don't do
anything until the show starts I did all
kinds of [__] today man I didn't know I
didn't say that I'm just saying you
could have waited to return that until
after the show but you didn't tell me
that you just told me I know but that
didn't mean you should have it right now
you should have messaged me that didn't
fit got her this damn no man I ain't
talking about
one of them damn Falcon net bras it just
grabs from the bottom see
yeah yeah it's nice it's hard buying
online [__] through the shirt yeah it's
hard buying bras online though because
right and especially this one it kept
telling you well buy two or three sizes
bigger than your regular size no because
it really small and so or yeah two or
three or whatever and so
and so we got it but it was like way too
big
is it two or three sizes buy it two
three sizes smaller than your normal
size because the size chart is all
[__] up yeah the set of 38 38 chests
was 3XL
it's like nah
but I got her in XLS is it two sizes
down it's still [__] two it's still
too big
still [__] two I probably should have
just got it regular it's gonna be like a
medium medium or an alarm yeah because
it's stretchy anyway yeah yeah so yeah
it was way too big yeah
Camp guy said uh I'm just about to get a
rear view camera for our travel trailer
I have absolutely no way to see directly
behind it when it's hooked up yeah I'm
really glad they actually have that as a
as an option nowadays so you can
actually see when you're backing up so
you don't back over somebody I wouldn't
mind to have a heads up display inside
my motorcycle helmet has a camera on the
back of my helmet
inside that way just a hole in it
instead of so he'd had to run mirrors
you can just see behind you eyes in the
back your head literally
that'd be really good although would it
be like confusing no no I guess not no
it's just looking into your rear view
mirror be just like yeah it'd be like
having a review mirror up there
Kevin Donovan said what size cup is he
or she [__] you
[__] pure [__] muscle dude
yeah girl sizes I'd probably be a b
you probably would be yeah
whether it be a type B
man stop [__] oh you love it thank
you very much Jeffy art tonight I'm
starting my new summer job as bar
security so I can't be on for too long
but I'll be catching you guys later when
I come home oh it's awesome you got a
new job kicks kick some drunk people
yeah [__] them up well I mean if they
deserve it yeah yeah they'll just like
kick people out randomly obviously but
yeah
so yeah it's Wednesday night it's our
main show and once again True Crime
there's one in the poll yeah but that's
okay with me because I like doing True
Crime shifts without a uh South Korean
serial killer we mentioned in another
show they caught him
yeah and actually I okay so we did I
think it was back on episode 151.
and I don't even remember that was PR
that was prior to us doing live streams
yeah because we didn't start doing like
live streaming video and stuff like that
until like episode 200 right so this was
when it was still a slideshow so it was
like a long time ago
and we did a show that was just called
like Korean crime or something like that
and it had this case uh the huasion
serial killer case and it also had the
Frog boys like the four boys that had
disappeared and then they turned up
murdered later on
so I um had kind of like forgotten about
it but then somebody messaged me and
said well you know you should do a
revisit on uh the huasion case because
they
um sort of kind of caught well they
closed the case like they know who did
it like the guy confessed and everything
and um they actually caught him
well they knew it was him or they were
pretty sure it was him back in 2019 but
I don't think they announced it until
like 2020. so it's been like a couple
years I just didn't hear about it
uh thank you murder Hornet for KY Jelly
for the only fans projects
thank you we probably won't need that
she won't cover it dude
we've spent so much money already on
this on like supplies for this yeah
supplies for this [__] already
uh Jeffy art said on his uh bar security
job on the job I'll ask myself what
would Tom do
well don't do that don't do don't do
what Tom would do necessarily
um Ben says my mother has one of these
new modern cars she got last year and
it's like a computer game cameras all
around and it beeps and shows you lines
of how far to turn Etc dude that's
pretty cool
uh hey there Hugo oh yeah we have to did
you make his shirt
uh no I never made it because I never
got the money yeah we got the money oh
you got the money oh yeah I got the
money and I got your address
I'll do it tomorrow so just print it
tomorrow and we will mail it uh before
the weekend all right should I get you a
medium
uh uh I guess so look at what it says
medium is I mean it's well it doesn't
matter obviously it says medium is 29.
see I don't know just maybe get a large
what'd you get before uh
uh 3XL oh we'll just get a large then
it has a lot of stretch in it though
well I well
I don't know I just don't want to go the
opposite way and it's very small you
know what I mean okay
all right
this must be Chinese sizes
yeah I'm like since when is it just like
it might be sold out
yeah it was sold out
sold out and large only pink ones we'll
get a medium then all right
okay go back to the show Jen let me I'll
buy it look at that [__] look at that
[__] he can't even focus on like one
thing on the show
look man I'm enthralled by bras he's
getting distracted yeah get distracted
by bros there's nothing even in that
brush it's the bra
that one see
it looks so good on you okay
all right we're gonna get a meeting
all right
Ben says talking about the car on the
downside she says it detects old lines
still painted on the road and tries to
grab the steering wheel from her to
correct oh [__] well that's not good
that's not good
that would probably scared the [__] out
of me
so uh so yeah
so uh so as I mentioned
somebody uh somebody told me that this
case had been solved
so like a couple years ago and I hadn't
heard about it so I thought it would be
a good time to do a revisit and
especially because
you know back when we did this show like
I said it was still a slideshow and I
think we were still trying to keep the
show down to an hour right remember when
we did that remember when we tried that
yeah and well we did it for a while yeah
but it it kind of necessitated me
editing a lot of stuff out like to keep
it down to you know what I mean well we
were following the rules of that era
right they were saying that well you
know
the algorithms and the statistics say if
you know if it's longer than an hour
then people don't watch it that's the
way the old YouTube was now everything's
long format
well that it just seems like it's all
over the place or like whatever you know
what I mean I actually heard it like you
know a couple hours that's quite that's
what is the most common that's what
people evidently watch
they're like long form stuff yeah yeah
it's because they're driving and
sleeping and
you know yeah well I mean that's kind of
why like a lot of channels I like that
tell this this scary story like
Supercuts and stuff yeah some of those
are like four or five hours long yeah
it kills time
well yeah because I like to put them on
in the background like while I'm working
and things like that that's other people
are doing listening in a scary story
makes your [__] work day go by fast
yeah that's true
uh Dana Rowling said it'd be cool to see
Tom make a Youtube short video of him
making the shirt
uh there's there's not gonna be anybody
here that can record it yeah because
I'll be at work yeah
but I could set up a uh
I might be able to put it you can set it
up on thing on the tripod
right through yeah that yeah that might
be neat you could put it up on the
channel as short just put up in order to
short yeah yeah it's a it's a large
pliskin or a little placekin image I
imagine the large the large one okay
yeah
but uh yeah so I don't even remember
what I'm talking about we keep getting
like distracted and stuff [__] happens
but you yeah
yeah but um you kind of sort of
remembered this yeah I I kind of liked
doing this I wanted to revisit the show
too because you know you were stationed
in Korea for a little while yeah and I
remembered like you know the
descriptions of where these buys were
found and stuff I thought it was just
school girls but you said no it was old
ladies too
yeah it was just kind of like like
whatever women were around it seemed
like opportunity right it was near it
was near like if I remember correctly
like bus stops people waiting for the
bus to school school time in the morning
that kind of [__] and they were finding
them down inside the drainage ditches
that are on the sides of the road in
Korea they're lined with concrete it's
kind of a nice little three foot deep
four foot wide drainage ditch on either
side of the roads it snows a lot rains a
lot during monsoon season
it's just a real expedient place to roll
somebody off down in that ditch and cars
may not see them because they're pretty
deep
you guys said he wants a little skin
loader a little one okay okay so just
don't forget
just a large Circle
but um yeah so I so I was gonna say and
I think I brought this up before and I
think I've reviewed this movie too but
if you've seen the bong joon-ho movie
um that came out in 2003 called Memories
of murder uh he's the guy that made
parasite you know all of that
um it's kind of loosely based on this
case now obviously at the time that the
movie came out
um they didn't know who the guy was and
so famously you know this is kind of a
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
movie but you know it's 20 years old at
this point uh there's a great scene at
the end where the main character who's
like the you know investigator that's
like looking into the case like looks
straight at the camera as though he's
looking out in the audience like looking
to see if he can find the Killer and so
they're speculating too that well since
they know who the Killer is now that he
probably did go and see the movie
because he seemed like that kind of but
he probably didn't give a [__] because
when they caught him um seems like he's
a little bit of a psychopath yeah
you know what I mean yeah I would think
so
um yeah and this case also has because
like I said it's been a long time since
we did it so I don't even remember how
much we went into this but this case
also has a really really sad case of a
dude that was wrongfully accused uh of
one of the murders and spent more than
20 years in prison damn
we get that time back
and actually if you look on YouTube
there's a really good two-part
documentary about this case there's not
a huge amount of other stuff about it
but there um there is like a really good
and each part is like 45 minutes
and they have like an extensive uh
interviews with that guy because he's
out now obviously
um you know of course the poor
[__] I mean it's like the whole
situation is just like really really
terrible but you know he's out now and
he seems pretty chill I mean
you know seeing what happened to him
it's just you know what I mean
somebody's trying to uh Pookie yeah what
are you doing why are you being bad yeah
yeah she just wants attention
Camp guy said my daughter went to South
Korea with her dance school traveling
performers when she was about 11 years
old they did Tennessee Buck dancing and
clogging in South Korea yeah man I
remember I remember doing clogging in
elementary that would be like something
the Koreans would want to see yeah well
it was so cultural
yeah show me the dance of your people
yeah
so these are the troubles these are the
tribal uh outfits
yeah did they explain on like big cowboy
boots and like Checkers probably check
shirts and [__] stuff like that yeah
it's like we don't really trust the uh
well some people do but when they go to
the country bar the skirts all had bib
it would have called like aprons and
bibs on them
yeah remember when everybody was wearing
those even Tom wore those back in the
day yeah right
all right
so uh so yeah
I don't think oh boy Tammy just joined
the channel thank you very much welcome
to flash bulbs
Tammy breaking off in flashpose trying
to get free porn
I give out some samples [__] yeah you
did
[Laughter]
yeah the response was good
ran to buy some of my friends in the
industry because you guys are gonna make
a lot of money
we were getting job offers and [__] but
no no you want to go bro what yeah I
don't want to do you want to go bro
you're gonna [__] all these dudes yeah
no thanks yeah no we're going to be
working with each other like no we're
gonna you and the gang bang Thursday and
this and this and they need you it
wouldn't work it wouldn't work I would
not like that
like I said that's the only reason I
wanted to do this because it was just me
yeah yeah you know what I mean yeah like
I don't want a bunch of random people
involved well there's another thing you
know I got permission to talk about it
uh one of our regulars he and his
girlfriend are making content
along those yeah and he's setting it and
sharing it
pretty spicy yeah her name is her name
is Misty she was cute
she wants to work with Jed I'll show Jed
the video she's like oh yeah she's cute
yeah
he wants he's in Texas he wants to come
down here
he told me I could say the name is Oscar
Oscar Perez Perez he's in here sometimes
yeah he's sometimes yeah yeah I'll show
y'all he's you show you these tapes that
you could yeah he said okay
I cleared it with him
okay yeah Tammy says oh I'm already a
patron yeah that's right just splitting
it up a little
that's okay I think this whatever works
I think this phone has
either this the other phone
some of this I can't show well obviously
um
that's on the other phone keep going Jim
okay
uh murder one that said Jen you look
very good thank you that test must have
worked good on the weight loss
um yeah I've actually lost a little bit
of weight in the last couple weeks just
because I haven't been eating all that
much
I could you know what I mean I just kind
of have it's actually last night when I
got I was so busy I didn't even eat
dinner or anything I just and then Tom
was at bike night so I came home and I
know the [__] I had to do and I did all
this stuff and then it was like 10
o'clock and he came home and I was like
oh my God I'm so [__] tired and then
I just wanted to lay down and put a
blanket on my over my face and he comes
up and he shoves a turkey sandwich at me
yeah he's like you have to eat something
yeah well she's complaining I didn't get
anything to eat and I'm feeling good I
wasn't complaining I was just saying I
didn't even have time to eat anything
because normally when he goes to bike
night you know I just stop at the deli
or the Chinese restaurant or something
just bring something home but I didn't
really have time to do that because I
had too much [__] to do and then like at
the end I was like man I'm not really
that hungry anyway [__] it and so I
wasn't really worried about it
but then it was starting to get late and
I'm like now it's kind of too late to
eat but you know but then he's just like
I hooked her up okay
yeah he's like you have to eat something
it was super funny
but yeah so that's probably why I just
I've been you know not I don't think for
two weeks I haven't I've been skipping
breakfast and I've been like I cut way
back on lunch and [__] like that today
though Tom made an eggplant lasagna
that was actually really good that we
just had an hour or two ago
but yeah so uh let's get into the case
before it gets super super late I don't
have a ton a ton a ton of stuff well
maybe I do I have like two and a half
pages or something like that
but um what should oh okay yeah are you
getting the other thing should I not
yeah should I not get into it yeah yeah
you don't distract me
um
Michelle Misty
yep I gotta cover that up that's Misty
Kevin says what is flash bulbs that's
just like what we call our membership
yeah
that's just we call her like you know
you can become a YouTube member
she was telling Jen that she's 19. she's
not 19. she's [__] 30. because I kind
of laughed when he told me that I was
like oh my God In The Cradle this is a
good one too they're at the bar and she
reaches up inside
Oscar's pantley in his short legs
whoa whoa whoa whoa he's at the bar
okay so that was that's who we're
talking about
but yeah that's just if you become a
YouTube member we just call it flash
bulbs because that's what Tom always
says all the time like you know show us
those flash bulbs and I think yeah so I
thought I got that from airplane to call
the membership then that was the two
black dudes going into the airplane and
the News camera the new remember from
airplane to first one yeah the two black
dudes are going to the airport and the
news crew was out front taking taking
pictures and it [__] the paparazzi
was there and he goes let me let me see
some of them flash bulbs did you
remember that yeah yeah I mean it's been
a while since I've seen yeah well for
some reason I
seeing that [__] the money popping up on
there it's like seeing flash moves let's
give me some flash balls that's that's
the joke I've been saying it for a long
time and yeah context has been lost
we started between me and red my uncle
that's where it first came from really I
didn't know that yeah because
whenever he wanted something from he
said let me see he's gonna flash Bros he
might want candy like he might have some
M M's you know so we can see them in
Flash balls
that's where it started meanwhile kids
today are like what the [__] is a flash
ball
well we used to watch the airplane we
[__] loved it it was back when cable
would play the same [__] over and over
again like [__] you know at HBO early
age they were back in the old days now
this was when I was when I was a kid and
I'm you know old
but um remember you had those cameras
that had the little flash but you had to
like click them on there yeah yeah it's
spin yeah you need to [__] you
advance the film mechanically in the
[__] time yeah okay man [__] it was
yeah yeah
then you had to take the pictures to the
[__] store to get developed crazy so
you can even take like dirty ones or
anything like that I mean you could but
there's yeah Kevin's understanding he
loves airplane yeah it was a good movie
it's still funny like we watched it
probably like a year ago I'm like yep so
funny the [__] captain of the
airplanes up there talking a little kid
so uh do you ever see Gladiator movies
men's prisons
making a move on a little kid [__]
funny yeah that's a hilarious [__]
movie like I said it's still funny
airplane two isn't quite as funny but
the first airplane is like still really
funny I thought
a lot of the um
because we talk a lot about how comedy
doesn't always yeah age all that well
but I think that one actually did just
because most of the jokes are so [__]
ridiculous
so uh so yeah are we ready now can I
actually like get into talking about the
case then you can throw in if you have
anything to say about Korea in general
yeah
so uh yeah now there are actually a
couple of different uh famous and I
think that maybe there's one serial
killer that's more famous in Korea so a
lot of times I'd I started watching this
one YouTube video that I thought was
about this case but it was actually
about the other one I'm like wait this
isn't right but you know I mean but um
this one probably the second Vape the
most famous serial killer and it
happened between
1986 and 1991.
so uh and this happened in a city called
huasion
and at the time not sure about now it
was like really really rural it's like
up in the mountains basically I was
watching the documentary about it and
they had some people that had lived
there at the time like when this was all
going on and they said basically it's
not even really a town it was just like
a collection of houses and like everyone
kind of knew each other you know what I
mean so it was like way out in the
middle of nowhere
so um so during this time period this
you know four or five years between 86
and 91. uh there were a a very long
series of rapes and murders
um that were you know all all against uh
women but there wasn't any particular
type it was all kind of like it was
teenagers some women in their 20s and
then some elderly women as well so it
seemed like it was just kind of like a
crime of opportunity type of thing
and for 33 years this crime was unsolved
and as I said a dude was actually
wrongfully convicted and served a
significant amount of time in prison but
as of 2019
they actually announced that they knew
who did it although uh we're gonna get
into this in a little bit too but at the
time that the crimes were going on
South Korea had a 15-year statute of
limitations on murder yeah so if you got
away with murder for 15 years then
you're off scott for even if they caught
you they couldn't convict you for it
yeah sounds crazy but there's probably
reasons for it well yeah I mean they're
because they're seeing this maybe the
evidence is so old by then when the law
was written it was probably like a
protection right because of being
accused against something that was
falsely accused against an old murder
because they're protecting people
probably like well that evidence is so
old
that is probably you know what I mean
the chances of it being
relevant has probably passed you know
what I mean that's probably what they're
talking about
because it could be that
you could take an old if you had an
enemy you could find an unsolved murder
that happened a long time ago and say he
did it and there'd be no way to disprove
it type of deal right you know what I
mean so it might be what they're talking
about well and they kind of went into
this a lot on the documentary too is
that during the time period that the
murders were going on like the late 80s
this was kind of during a kind of
tumultuous time in Korean history they
were going through democratization uh
process but there was still like a lot
of
um public protests against like police
brutality and like human rights abuses
and things like that so the cops at the
time were very
authoritarian uh they didn't really have
much in the way of scientific
investigative tools basically they were
just like well we're gonna bring in a
dude and beat a confession out of him
and voila it solved that's pretty much
like what and that's pretty much what
happened in this case too yeah to be
honest you know I lived there for a year
and
worked with both militaries ours and
theirs
and was up near the GSA conference I was
at Camp Grieves a long time ago it's
gone now it's now now my old Camp is now
a museum they do like [__] tours
through there this is the way it used to
be you know
um
South Korea was a vassal state to the
United States
it was a military dictatorship dressed
up to look like a democracy that's not
it was it was a dictatorship
now there was some justification for it
it was under the stress of War
like when you're under the stress of War
democracies can't really work that well
uh you'll get your ass kicked
if you let if you let uh two opposing
sides inside a country fight each other
they'll use the enemy as like a fulcrum
to [__] overcome their political
enemies inside the country either side
will do it
so when you're under this stress of
long-term War like that and you're as
relatively weak as South Korea was
you're better off as a dictatorship it's
more simple it's more stable
which is a very Un-American thing to say
but it's very true dictatorships are
extremely stable
look at North Korea it's uncollapsible
because it's collapsed so long ago it
it's it's it's whittled itself down to
being a trilobite it can't be get any
more simple or any more primitive
anything that could happen to that
country has already happened to it so
it's extremely stable
Ben says you have to have some statutory
limit on criminal charges our Western no
time limits on murder charge system is
quite anachronistic I agree in some
circumstances serial murder I think
would be an exception
um you know other criminal charges yeah
it's like I'm not bothered about you
know
lesser charges like you know 10 15 years
20 years down the line like if they
don't catch you then you know they write
it off or whatever I don't really have a
problem with that in this case though
um because the crimes were so heinous
and so egregious and there were so many
of them
um you know I I think I definitely think
that they should and the thing about it
was they kind of lucked out because you
know spoiler alert he was already in
jail for something else
um when they found out who he was uh
because had he been
caught for the murders they did overturn
the um the statute of limitations for
murder in 2015 partially in response to
this particular case but it wasn't
um retroactive meaning that you know
they couldn't go back and apply it to
people that had already you know what I
mean it was just going forward so even
if they had even if he was still walking
around free and they were like oh that's
the guy they couldn't have done anything
to him but luckily like I said he was
already in prison for something else so
he's in prison even though it's not for
this even though he did but they did but
they know he did do this
so yeah so like I said this happened
between 1986 and 1991
this is not this was right before you
were in Korea right because you were in
Korea in the early 90s yeah 1990 to 91.
okay so this was about the time that
that was going on like the the tail end
of it
so yeah so um as I mentioned huasion is
a you know really really kind of out the
middle of nowhere sort of place and
hence one of the reasons why because I
think a lot of people said well a lot of
the victims were
you know were women that were like
walking
to or from a bus stop like two or from
work like really early in the morning or
really late at night and they're like
what the hell are they doing that for
one it's a small town and serial killing
was practically unheard of in Korea at
this point and also because the town was
so rural it didn't really have a lot of
bus routes like it didn't come through
there very often so it's just kind of
like well you had to take the bus
whenever it came like whenever your job
was or whatever so it wasn't it wasn't
real uncommon for women of all ages to
be walking around you know alone at
night like to or from a bus stop or like
walking a long way like back to their
house so that's why because that's
pretty much where most of the victims uh
were attacked
so the first victim of the serial killer
who was not identified at the time was
actually a 71 year old woman and her
name was Lee won in now she had been
visiting her daughter
this was uh September 15th 1986 and this
was kind of like you know late afternoon
evening it was about six o'clock in the
evening
now they actually found her body
um in like a pasture
now initially because she was kind of
off on the side of the road initially
they thought that it was a hit and run
because one they don't think of like as
though it's not a serial killer you know
what I mean they wouldn't think of that
because it just didn't happen all that
often and she was just laying on the
side of the road so they thought
initially it was a hit and run so they
didn't really treat it as a murder at
first but then like when she went in she
was autopsied
um it turned out that she had been raped
and murdered now one interesting thing
she'd been strangled actually one
interesting thing that one of the guys
on the documentary said was that
um one of the things too was that in
the police didn't really believe that an
elderly woman could be raped like like a
rapist wouldn't go after an elderly
woman there's got to have context for
this right
Korea is the most homogeneous society on
the planet
they're damn near cousins they're almost
they're just all related they've been
there forever
this type of violent crime is not common
there
sexual assaults usually happen in like
you know the itaewon district
or in other places that's kind of like
the party
parts of the town and it's between horny
old dudes and
young working women of the night if you
understand that's where mostly going on
but and you know that's where that kind
of [__] goes on
so they don't
it's the old woman who who'd want to
have sex with an old woman that's what
they're thinking if that's what the guy
said yeah yeah he's like that's why it's
ridiculous that's why at first they
didn't really treat it as kind of like
yeah that's very un on Korean very
unasian for them sexuality is something
for young people
you know having sex with a woman over 30
God that's ridiculous gross whoa
look at Japan look at Japan I mean you
know the sexual orientation of Japan
just listen to Japanese female porn
stars that's over 30 years yeah
some of the if you ask me some of the
best looking of the Japanese porn stars
come to the United States they're nice
figures on them and in their 30s and
stuff and
they would say why do you come here
because well all our fans are here and
what about Japan because nah the
Japanese guys they like skinny girls
that look like they're about 13. that's
that's really the top thing there
you know the West has I would say more
healthy tastes
my opinion I think it's right but
there's something about
skinny women with no shape that just
doesn't turn me on at all
I mean like I said everything it's like
child stuff but yeah I do kind of feel
like the Japanese are in what's called
neotni yeah you know which is the type
of look that this childlike look
Kawaii
you know if the girls got nice cans
she's going to tie them down to make
herself look flat chested that's how
ridiculous it is
that's ridiculous
here bad [__] girl be sporting them
things man
because the dudes respond
Japanese guys don't respond to that
Koreans are kind of like that but not as
much
the Koreans are kind of like the Latins
of the [__] Asia they're the sexy
ones they're the sexy ones I said that
one time the Korean girl said thank you
yes thank you now Koreans are [__]
spicy for for Asia
yeah well and the thing about it and a
lot of um the the people in the
documentary which you know they talk to
cops that investigated the case people
that lived in the you know in the town
when it was going on and stuff like that
so you know it's I think it was like a
an American or a British produced
documentary but it was all in Korean you
know so it all had uh subtitles but yeah
a lot of them were saying
that it was more the era than anything
else like they just because they weren't
used to
um you know really caring that much or
having that you know all this kind of
violent crime sexual assault serial
murder
um they didn't really have a lot of that
going on or a lot of it wasn't reported
um and because the cops were kind of
like corrupt or they didn't really give
a crap or they just kind of
you know they just they covered a lot of
stuff up and actually one of the
criminologists on there she said that
she believed that there were probably a
lot more of the crimes like rapes or
murders or whatever like in this series
that were kind of swept under the rug
like just because it because the police
looked bad because the public kept
having this huge outcry all these
murders kept happening in this small
town and they're just like why aren't
you doing anything like why aren't you
catching him because you know
so they were under a lot of pressure to
just kind of you know put anybody up
there and that's what ended up happening
to this poor guy which we'll get into in
a little bit but they just wanted to
like solve it
or look like they were doing something
but they didn't really have because they
said at the time they didn't have the
capacity to do DNA they didn't have
really all they could do was blood
typing and you know according to the
criminologists that were talking on
there they said um pretty much the cops
at that time in South Korea were almost
entirely dependent on confession so like
I said if you weren't saying what they
wanted you to say then they would
essentially like beat it out of you or
they would like torture it out of you
yeah and then they'd be like well we got
him case closed it would be like that
yeah and that was Korean saying this
like criminologists and stuff that had
been around at the time they were like
yeah it was it was not a good time yeah
that's not unique to Korea well no of
course not China and Japan are like that
too
it's just part of their culture they're
very authoritarian
and if the the authorities were wrong
they will never admit that they are
wrong never
they'll let you go if you commit if if
they're wrong and they will come at you
and says look we're wrong if you go
ahead and just confess we'll let you go
wait a minute what yeah you know that
but that it's because uh
going back thousands of years probably
back in China to the concept of Chinese
emperor worship the emperor is never
wrong he's Celestial to admit that he's
wrong and fallible then people won't
believe in it that's that's the thinking
which man that's no no dude not at all
government is an amorphous thing
constantly changing it has to be beaten
into shape by the people
the people have to keep government under
control that's just read the
enlightenment writings of the [__]
1700s of how bad government can get when
they're talking about France and England
although England was actually pretty
good in the 1700s it's just that we were
pissed at him they were telling us what
to do over here in the colonies and we
just got sick of that if you're not the
boss of us you're not the boss of me
yeah that's exactly that's really what
it was throwing all your tea in the
harbor God damn yeah
the Redcoats were actually good
it's just they were unrealistic they
wanted us to [__]
not make our own shovels and buy their
shovels that kind of stupid [__] just
was very impressive dude I just want to
shovel it you just want a shovel you can
just make one yeah you don't have to
Bing or put it on the boat and put it on
forcing us to make wooden shovels
because you know now you have to make a
wooden shovel because if you want a real
shovel you got to buy it from us the
Empire doesn't work for long
Ben says their legal systems are based
on confession yeah that's what they were
saying in ancient China they couldn't
convict someone unless they confessed
and torture was allowed yeah so they got
convictions right of course I kind of
feel like that's what happened during
like this trials yeah yeah we're just
gonna pull your thumbs off until you say
you're a witch okay break your legs
slowly with these crushing screws right
and then no you'll tell us what we need
to do yeah yeah uh even [__] even the
Romans didn't do that kind of [__]
you know thousands of years before 1500
years before even the Romans I mean to
me that's just intensely dominant and it
just seems like somebody that just wants
to do it because they're sadistic more
than more than they actually think
they're getting truth out of anybody
yeah although in the defense of the
medievals
it wasn't uniform there were certain
areas where they weren't about that
they're like that's [__] crazy yeah
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't across the
board just we're remembering the places
where it was bad there were parts of the
middle middle ages that were pretty good
in certain areas like you know you could
go there it would be like a foreign
country you could live all right if you
were a modern person
but other places you didn't want to go
there
the Roman trial was more about show
business they just put you up in front
of a crowd and just argued the case and
if you were a good Entertainer you might
get off
yeah yeah because they
there was no real concept of evidence or
forensic evidence he just had to kind of
argue for yourself
that you didn't do it
and uh and it was just a crowd of people
like I said a mob and bottom drop they
didn't have forensic science yeah so
it's not like they had any way to back
anything yeah it was basically who had a
better [__] story we had a better
story
Camp guy says the pillars of the earth
is a great novel by Ken Follett I agree
I uh read it a couple years ago that
gives a lot of info on the English way
of life in the 1600s
uh yeah that actually is a really really
good uh book I read it probably like
five years ago the great urine the great
European Empires in general were great
if you're an anglo-american you're going
to lean towards England and England was
good for law they were real good about
that real good for invention
when it came to power and expansion was
a Spanish the the Spanish Empire was the
[__] too now they weren't always at the
same levels over time over time the
Spanish Empire couldn't hold together
uh but really man the space Spain man
[__] almost all of Central and South
America they got that and ran it okay
did well with it
um you can go back and reinterpret
things but in general
they improved the area
as time went on
They're all playing with the Emojis now
now they're playing with Emojis now yeah
I like to where is that raccoon yeah and
there's there's the one that's you oh
yeah what am I doing here you probably
can't you just like with it oh okay
alarms and stuff like that there's the
smell of things to do one yeah all right
all right so let's get back to this [__]
because we were only on the first victim
so yeah the first victim 71 year old
woman uh raped and murdered found on the
side of the road in September of 1986.
now the second victim was a 25 year old
woman named Park Hyun souk now she was
coming home after uh she had a meeting
with a prospective marriage partner
because that was how they did that [__]
back then and this was October 20th 1986
uh and it was about 10 o'clock at night
and uh she like most of the victims she
had just gotten off the bus because she
was coming back from another town and
she kind of uh walked down the road you
know no one was around like toward her
house and she got attacked so her body
was found three days later in the
afternoon uh in a canal she had been
raped and also strangled now some of
them were strangled by hand and some of
them were ligatures 25 go 25.
the third victim was named guanjong bong
she was also 25. and she was a housewife
now this was probably like a little over
a month later this was just I mean this
was happening like in pretty quick
succession uh December 12 1986 and it
was about 11 o'clock at night she was
actually attacked and murdered in front
of her house so not even like going to
the bus
so her body was found much later down an
embankment she had been gagged and
strangled uh using her stockings which
was something of a signature of the
killer like going forward he would use a
lot of the victim's own clothing to
strangle them and restrain them when
they found her the gag was still in her
mouth yeah good uh yeah and she was like
tied up with her stockings and had been
raped all of the victims were raped as
far as I let people know what happened
yeah yeah
the fourth victim was a 23 year old
woman named Lee kiss Ki souk and she was
also coming home after meeting a
prospective marriage partner a lot of
that going around back then and uh she
was actually taken only two days after
the previous uh one but I think like the
the previous one's uh body wasn't found
until several months later but
um she was attacked like two days
afterward and it was about the same uh
time of night it was also 11 p.m uh
again she was had gotten off the bus
because she'd come back from another
town and her body was found a few days
later
uh between like and in some rice fields
and she had been uh like tied her hands
tied behind her back and she had been
strangled also
um she had been raped with an umbrella
uh this was another thing that would
that some of the victims would have
going forward the Killer
I don't know I don't really know yeah I
don't really know
um where he would like insert things
he's an insertion freak yeah like he did
it um to a few of them but yeah but this
was the first one that he did honestly
umbrella
yeah maybe so maybe can you shut up yeah
I'm not really sure just trying to
violate her in some way yeah
it's just I mean this dude what the [__]
man this is a [__] up [__]
so the next victim victim number five
was a 19 year old uh high school student
whose name was Hong Jin Young
and she was coming home from school uh
it was about 8 30 p.m so again she was
getting off the bus this was January 10
1987.
um she was actually found uh the
following day uh also in a rice field or
rice paddy or whatever uh and she had
her hands were also tied behind her back
she'd been gagged with socks and also
raped and strangled
the next victim was Park Eun Joo she was
a victim number six 29 years old also a
housewife she was actually her husband
was at work I guess like down the road a
little way and it was going to rain and
he'd forgotten his umbrella so she was
taking him his umbrella
um and on the way there she was attacked
uh her body was found uh seven days
after she disappeared so she disappeared
on May 2nd 1987 her body was found on
the ninth and uh she had also been raped
and strangled
the seventh victim was also a housewife
she was 54 years old her name was on GI
soon
and she was coming home uh this was
September 7th 1987 about 11 o'clock at
night uh and again she had gotten off
the bus and then got attacked
so um her body was found in a canal on
September 8th am in the morning
now she'd been tied up uh she'd been
gagged with socks and a handkerchief
she'd been strangled and raped and also
the killer had inserted Peach slices
into her vagina
I've heard Peach slices and I've also
heard a whole Peach not that it really
makes that much of a difference but I'm
just saying
uh sources differ on that so yeah so
again it was supposed to be a compliment
this is some good [__] here that's sweet
as hell
That's like [__] weird man yeah
that's so [__] weird yeah
well you know I'd heard in other cases
where they're putting rocks and gravel
and [__] like an insult
that is
that's weird
so I was thinking that that might be the
opposite
maybe it might have been some kind of
weird perverse compliment
gee thanks this is some good [__]
yeah
gross yeah
but hey these dudes are weird man oh
yeah you could say that yeah because
you're weird
murder Hornet said somewhere in Asia
they killed a girl Farmer they sucked
the handle inside her then kicked it in
said it went all the way to her organs
like Jesus Christ like a pickaxe handle
okay
[__] sake
thank you very much Aaron for the tip
jar happy Wednesday thank you very much
thank you so much that's awesome yep
that's awesome I could use every bit of
it I gotta pay bills around here pay
bills and buy stuff for the other
channel
camera
yep I want to get some rgbs too but get
some more RGB
LinkedIn yeah I think I want me to buy
those too
okay
all right murder Hornet said why serial
killers put weird [__] in why do they do
anything they do I mean because they're
[__] up they're outside in the wild
running out of things to do and the
woman's probably either dead or
semi-conscious and he just wants to put
something in there to kind of like I
said insult her it's it's a they're not
nice dude that's not the idea I mean I
guess it's just like another like
Integrity it's a way it would be great
yeah
I mean even dudes like BTK
he he'd be torturing some girl and he's
thinking he's like some kind of
gentleman
Bandit and giving them yeah he really
did he thought he was a nice guy yeah he
really didn't think that I need to tell
him look I got this problem I have to
kill you now I know it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be a lady kill him
yeah it's just I I really can't conceive
you you should read that book that
Sophie sent me that's like all his
letters and stuff like that that dude
yeah
that wigged me out like the way that
dude thinks it's just yeah it's out
there then there were other guys that
are just sexual sadists
you know some some uh [__] what's his
name Bundy was like that
and then after they were dead he was
doing stuff to the bodies just
increasing the sadism
there's people don't realize that the
weird [__] that he would do he'd like to
take take a head home with him put it in
the refrigerator and use that as a toy
yeah
for days and days yeah
put her head up on a damn mantle
yeah think about that next time somebody
talks about Ted Bundy being the hottest
cereal yeah no it was gross man he was a
necrophile he was [__] gross yeah
I mean people don't realize that he was
a necrophiliac yeah yeah somehow that
doesn't really get brought up all that
much I don't know why yeah but
see that's the thing if you're kind of
like you know uh sort of sort of
attractive I guess by conventional
standards then you get away with a lot
more yeah they they forget to mention
sir they forget to mention that it's
like hey he used to [__] like gross
decomposers I think he took a 13 year
old girl to an abandoned Pig
slaughterhouse raped her and then slit
her throat like a pig yeah and left her
there you know slaughter house floor and
he said he didn't do it but he did it
yeah for some reason it's like they
they'll admit to like everything else
but it's like usually if it's underage
girls well that was okay that was me I
didn't do that one I'm like [__] you
yeah it was him you might as well just
admit it yeah it was yeah yeah of course
it was he was disgusting scumbag but um
but yeah
I don't care what he looks like he's a
disgusting Scout and I don't personally
think he was that attractive anyway
but I mean you know by serial killer
standards I guess he was okay looking
but because that's only because the rest
of them were so [__] up looking
so uh so yeah
so victim number eight was a 14 year old
girl now her name was uh Park sang hee
and this was actually
um a little bit of a standout in the
series because she was actually not on
she wasn't outside she wasn't like
walking over the bus or school or
anything like that she was actually
asleep in her room uh in the middle of
the night and the Killer
broke into the house essentially and
raped and murdered her in her bedroom
um so the thing about it was that I
guess the house because I saw in the
documentary they showed um the house
they showed um kind of the police
footage of it and there was a wall
around the house that you know was
probably about eight nine feet tall I
want to say so the killer would have had
to like climb over that but they're like
once they did that I heard
some of the sources said oh well a door
was open and he just went in but then on
the documentary they said well a
traditional korean house at the time
would have had like the doors just slid
open and shut and then there would be
like paper so you could essentially just
like punch through the paper and like
undo the latch and get in so I'm not
sure which of the I mean you know like I
said it doesn't really matter he did get
into the house and killed that little
girl
but
um you know the but the wall around the
house that'll kind of come into play
like a little bit later on but yeah
because
um I saw like a footage of what the
house looked like and it was kind of
just like a wall around it but it wasn't
locked or anything so once you got over
the wall you could just get in there
pretty easily so yeah so again this was
kind of a different a slightly different
Mo even though she was left the same way
she would still strangling with her
clothes and stuff like that but he
actually like had gotten Bolder at this
point because he'd actually broken into
a house and raped and murdered a little
girl in her bed rather than like outside
now that was uh number eight so then the
ninth victim was another 14 year old
girl named uh Kim Mee Jung and she was a
middle school student and she was coming
home from school uh on November 15 1990.
um about 6 6 30 in the evening a very
foggy day it was
and she was uh attacked on her way back
home
so her body was found the following day
on a hill
um her hands and feet were tied she'd
been gagged with her bra
she'd also been strangled and raped and
she also had things inserted into her
vagina including a ballpoint pen a fork
a spoon and a razor blade
so it was that was post-mortem
probably I don't know actually because I
was thinking about that too like when I
was making the notes because I couldn't
really see like anything that said that
it was if it was pre or postmortem
because people are [__] kicking
around and thrashing and fighting
yeah you too hard
yeah probably
first Power 100 said Ted Ted Bundy's
last murder victim was 12 and she wasn't
even Bundy's youngest victim the
youngest one was I believe nine yeah so
not only that Not only was a necrophile
but he also killed little kids even
though he denied it yeah like I said
he's a [__] scumbag
but uh you know
uh and then the tenth victim uh was a 69
year old woman named Quan soon sang and
she was coming home uh at 9 00 pm on
April 3rd 1991 again getting off the bus
and she was attacked by the killer at
that point
um she was found the next day and had
been raped and strangled now these are
kind of like the 10 canonical murders
that they know were the same guy
so these serial murders were kind of as
I said you know the span of time that
this was going on from 1986 to 1991.
these weren't I mean serial killing
wasn't really a thing like in South
Korea they hadn't really seen anything
like this it's not a big country and it
doesn't have a huge population so
statistically it's not going to happen
as much there
that's why you know the cops weren't as
familiar with it you know yeah at first
I kind of feel like they were just
trying to say oh they're just unrelated
but I'm like well you know
they didn't really get on the serial
killer well they didn't have like the
serial killer you know Heyday that we
had yeah like in the 70s like the late
60s and 70s and and 80s to like a lesser
of design it's also not the correct
environment to produce large amounts of
serial killers
just
it's a different kind of society it's a
lot more chilled out
more traditional
and uh predictable the expectations of
men are a lot different
so
the pressures that you need aren't
really there
statistics have a lot to do with it
though too
like I think Japan also very low
incident of violence yeah they have a
very low they have Korea is very similar
you know I mean some I'm not gonna lie
some [__] up [__] does has happened in
Japan because I wrote about a couple
cases but it's very very uncommon yeah
even they're organized criminals are not
not really a big deal but by Western
standards you know what I mean like
people talk about the Yakuza all they
know about the Yakuza is what they saw
in some Hollywood movie
you can go on YouTube and see American
guys hanging out with the Yakuza they're
just regular guys
they're not doing say what Mexican Mob
does that's not how they make a living
they have offices and [__]
um they do things like handle legal
gambling debts and [__] try to collect
debts they're kind of more like
collection agents
um they do run brothels
but they're just running brothels other
people run brothels too
um
some of them will carry guns but very
rarely do they ever shoot or kill
anybody because they're dealing with
people that will pay up the money
eventually you know
so they don't it doesn't the Japanese
public doesn't require the heavy hand
that people in The American or even
Mexican uh Pub uh public would require
in other words you know if you're a
Mexican gangster and you owe a bunch of
money and
you know uh and you don't want to pay
it's going to take more Force to get you
to pay you know they're the police for
the criminals is what
organized crime is about really
and and they're trying to sell things
this [__] doesn't really exist the
savagery of the American continent
doesn't exist in
Korea and Japan in China
it's just not there
I hear Europeans say things it's
absolutely ludicrous by American
continent standards
you know
a European government could never
control
south or Central America ever
and barely control the United States
get your [__] killed
doing what European governments do just
wouldn't work here very unruly
Chantilly lay said Bundy was nasty I
wish they talked more about that yeah it
was real nasty yeah it really seems like
they do kind of gloss over like all the
Real gross [__] he did just because like
I said because by a serial killer
standards he was okay looking I suppose
first Power 100
um says then I'm gonna get to this
because he says um you young Chul is
still South Korea's worst serial killer
I yeah I heard about him when I was
researching this case and I said oh we
should do a show about this [__]
because he was uh um he was also a
cannibal put it on a list and he never
heard him yeah and he's um you don't
really hear a lot about him in the west
yeah I thought about it earlier because
I was like yeah we should probably do a
show about that dude as well because
there's not a lot of other stuff out
there about him I think I saw one
documentary
like like a 20-25 minute one that
somebody had done
what's up poke why are you scratching on
my chair
so uh so yeah this was kind of like the
first as far as I know
um this was like the first
serial Killing Spree like in Korea at
least that they know of like the you
know a series of crimes with the same
ammo pretty much
so
um so like I said the first crime in the
series which happened in 1986 which was
the older lady like in her 70s that they
initially thought was hit and run or
whatever and then when the next victim
that happened like about a month later
was younger I think initially up until
probably like the third or fourth murder
I think they thought these weren't
related you know what I mean because
they didn't really have the experience
with it yeah now once they finally did
figure out that this was probably the
same [__] doing all this
um they did actually kind of mobilize uh
you know a record number of police
officers to investigate the crime prior
to that there had really only been three
dudes working on the murders
um I should say too that at the around
the time of the first murders in the
series there was in Korea there was the
you know the Asia Games it was just kind
of like the big you know like the Asian
Olympics or whatever and that was going
on in Seoul so a lot of police officers
had been deployed to Seoul like to help
out with that because you know North
Korea had been making threats against it
they were gonna blow it up and all this
other kind of crap so they had all of
the um the cops there kind of so they
didn't really have a lot of cops
out in these like little Wilderness kind
of towns you know what I mean so they
only have three dudes on it at first but
once they started taking it seriously
they had a lot more dudes
so
eventually as the murders went on and
the public started freaking out I mean
as they would because they're like why
isn't the police doing anything why
can't you catch this guy they did end up
with over 21
000 suspects uh who they looked at and
interviewed
they also fingerprinted more than 40 000
people
and they took some DNA samples and hair
samples even though at the time they
didn't really have a good way of testing
them really all they could do was
fingerprints and blood typing you know
what I mean that was pretty much all
they did they didn't really have the
technology to do DNA in Korea in uh the
late 1980s
so
what they tried to do
once they determined that this guy was
striking in pretty much a Four mile
radius uh around this town this little
town uh they had all the cops go out and
they'd go out in pairs and they'd only
be like 300 feet apart and they're just
like kind of comb in the area looking
for the dude but you know they never did
find him and the next time that he
killed somebody
um he happened to kind of filter through
the net and get somewhere where the cops
weren't
um also they tried to like set traps for
them and [__] like that because there
had been a rumor started going around
it's not it wasn't entirely accurate but
I guess I know where they got the idea
from
um the the rumor was that the killer was
only targeting women that were wearing
red and that he only struck when it was
raining out and I think they did
actually if you see the um the bong Jin
Ho movie memories of murder I think
that's kind of like a big plot point
like the red clothes and the uh and the
rain and everything like that but I
don't think that's the case I don't
think it was always raining like and I
don't think all the women had read on
but I think enough of them did that
people made that Association you know
what I mean so what they would do was
they would have like female police
officers and they would put red clothes
on and like walk around by themselves at
night like hoping to bait the guy into
attacking them but he never did like it
never worked
um and they did that and I guess I I
understand like how the townsfolk were
getting a little hoping some
Superstition could help him out because
they built a like a scarecrow
essentially that they put like red
clothes on and it said something on it
like
um what did it say it said something it
was like a threat like to the guy so
they were hoping it would like frighten
him away it was like some kind of like
magic or something
now
interestingly a couple people did see
who they thought was the Killer
um like they had this the bus driver and
the conductor on the bus they did see a
guy get on the bus like after like not
too long after the the seventh victim
had been murdered like in 1988
and uh so the bus drivers say they
actually were able to they did like a
famous um you know like a composite
sketch of him
and there also had been several women
who had been raped but not murdered and
they had also given the police a
description of this dude
so the description at the time they said
he was very Slender Man
um probably for that time average height
about five five five six they said he
was in his early to mid 20s they're
pretty sure
um had short
hair like that was kind of like a sporty
cut what they would call it
um and a sharp nose a lot of them said
that
I don't know what that is for a cruise I
don't I don't know what that is either
but that was something that a lot of
them said the witnesses they say that
Caucasians have long noses which I don't
really understand it either or tall
noses that's what they call it tall nose
are they talking about this way or this
way I don't know
I would think they were talking about
like that yeah I would think so too
maybe
but I don't know I don't know what that
means
that's just the way they describe it I
had some Korean guy one time with the
soul
we had to go deliver some paperwork we
were on some special
[__] detail it was legal paperwork
because some [__] that [__] went down
to the unit
and uh me and the NCO had to go to this
[__] it was like a joint
headquarters where
American Army and this and the Korean
army [__] have the same offices
as I was walking in there a Korean NCO
he was E5 a sergeant comes right up to
me and he [__] marches right up to me
and [__] stops and [__] hit puts
his face right in my [__] face and
I'm like what the [__] is this all about
and then he goes and he points in my eye
like that and he goes blue
I went no green
and he had never seen colored eyes just
Brown yeah I guess they wouldn't and he
goes back and looking at he's looking at
looking at and all of a sudden I can see
that he starts
to dry heave
almost like to throw up okay it's all
right man it's all right because it had
Disturbed him so much
weird and then he shook it off so he'd
really never seen anyone with blue or
green no and it almost caused him to
throw up
that seems like a weird thing that would
make you throw up yeah he had never seen
it he'd never seen it firsthand
I think he was I don't think he worked
there I think he was just visiting there
he had heard he had seen it only in
photos
and then he shook it off he started
spitting it's all right man it's all
right he's like yeah yeah it's all right
sorry it's all right sorry and then he's
like it's okay it doesn't hurt you see
and he wanted it doesn't hurt yeah he
was hurt no it's okay you know
yeah that's pretty crazy weird
that was in there it was in the very
early 90s they're probably not like that
now I would imagine not yeah that seems
very I understood it you know what I
mean they're they're very homogeneous
they don't see people of other races
still though oh but oh by a western
standards they would be racist wouldn't
let you into restaurants and stuff but
you just kind of have to forgive them
there
they don't know what they're talking
about they're scared well like I said
now I mean nowadays in a in a
westernized country if you want to call
it that like with the internet and
everything like that I don't think
there's any excuse anymore well yeah but
this is in the western western country
it's Korean well no I know but I'm just
I'm talking westernized just in the
sense of yeah you know having the
internet and having access to the same
yeah movies and [__] like that that
everybody else does which they do well
you can go on YouTube and go look at
channels like Korean girls react or
Koreans react and [__] they got
basically internet celebrities and
low-level celebrities reacting to
Western things and [__] and they just
react to the way Western girls dress
they like it but they say like oh you
could never we could never dress like
that and what they're talking about is
exposing arms or exposed backs on
dresses
it's that that's how vanilla they are
and then they see a girl who's like
curvy with like big boobs and a nice
butt and they they cannot believe that a
person can be built like that
like wow you know the girl's like man I
wish I had everything over you know they
were like man that'd be nice and they're
making jokes about it and [__] you know
like how's that possible how's that
possible
you know and actually I think at the
time you know they were talking it was a
Latina girl who was you know
doubly you know double g
top and [__]
just hourglass shape you know with a
nice booty and that would just blow
their [__] minds and the guys thought
it was too big
the Korean guys another guy goes so yeah
but that's you know that it has a
certain look to that you know what I
mean so some guys kind of liked it but
the girls liked it better than the guys
it's not always the way
girls recognize hyper femininity
they liked it yeah
the guys I think they were just oh no oh
no
she might beat me up uh maybe it's I
might it might be more like uh I may not
be man enough for that that's probably
what you know like yeah she's gonna be
going for another guy like man that's
some Jessica Rabbit [__] yeah Jessica
Rabbit and that's the way she was built
Jessica Rabbit
so uh so yeah so they did have a
description of this guy like I said they
had a composite sketch a couple of the
women that had survived sexual assaults
also said that he had soft hands
which I guess in this rural community
would kind of be a big deal because it
wasn't somebody that like worked in a
farm or something like that uh so yeah
so that was another thing that a couple
of them uh pointed out
now here's where the cops made kind of a
[__] up that um
you know uh impacted the case quite
greatly
they mistakenly uh as it turned out they
didn't actually know they were mistaken
until much later but they mistakenly
said that the suspect had type B blood
uh as I said later on when they actually
caught the real guy that did it uh
turned out that he didn't have type B
blood he had type O blood
but you know
um so yeah
now as I mentioned before because there
was so much pressure on the police to
solve this case
um there was a horrible miscarriage of
justice that occurred after the eighth
murder which if you remember was the one
with the 14 year old girl that was
murdered in her bed like in her house
and what ended up happening was that the
cops hauled in
uh a then 22 year old man named Yoon
sung Hyo yo
um in 1989
and he was only arrested for that one
murder but they were kind of like
implying that he had killed the other
women as well
now here's the thing
what they um argued I'm not sure
entirely like how he specifically came
to the attention to police they were
kind of like going through pretty much
everybody that lived in that area
because like I said it wasn't a huge you
know it wasn't a huge population
so they were kind of like interviewing
everybody
what ended up happening was that at that
particular crime scene they found some
uh pubic hairs and like some other hairs
and these hairs had traces of uh
titanium
and because Yoon worked as a welder
um and also had similar like titanium uh
you know in his hair fibers that was one
thing that they used uh against him
and uh basically they also had
they they hauled him in this poor guy
is he wasn't um super educated he grew
up very poor we'll get into this in a
little bit
but he was
um disabled like he had had a polio when
he was three uh and on the interview
like on the documentary when he was
talking about it he said yeah it's like
you know rich people back then when he
was three years old um you know could
afford to get vaccinated but I was poor
so I couldn't get vaccinated so he got
polio when he was three and it
essentially like crippled him for life
so he's on the documentary which was
made in 2020 or 2021 and he still walks
you know he can walk but you know kind
of
not all that great so so they hauled him
in
and they kept him in custody for three
days
they did not let him sleep they did not
give him any food
and when he wouldn't uh allegedly when
he wouldn't tell them that he was the
killer
um they basically just started like
kicking the [__] out of him and they
would also kind of like make him
um you know kind of like squat up and
down like that which she couldn't really
do because like I said he's crippled I
mean he he had Polio like his legs are
all like that you know what I mean like
if you like like I said he can walk but
you know it was difficult this is by
this time yeah yeah and they didn't
report that the dude had been crippled
by polio well see this that's what's
dumb it's like yeah you'd think that
that would be because it's very obvious
like if you see him walk it's very
obvious that he had had Polio like when
he was a kid it's very obvious like the
way he was and the way his legs are
configured he's desperate to get an
arrest they well yeah that's what they
were and they I did I got him and what
they used they used his disability to
say oh well because he's disabled he's
mad at women because they wouldn't
because he can't get laid Yeah so he
decided he was just gonna go take it and
they beat the [__] out of this poor guy
and you know like I said would have
definitely said no he was crippled yeah
yeah you'd think that that would be one
of the first things you would notice
right yeah [__] still dumbasses right
but like you said they were so desperate
they had to have known I'm sure they did
they had to have known
so the thing about to get an arrest the
thing about it too and like I said they
specifically arrested him for the one
murder that you know that happened
inside the girl's house right but then
they kind of implied yeah he did the
other ones too like we caught the serial
killer but remember how I said before
how to get into that girl's house you
would have had to climb over like an it
looked like about an eight foot wall
like I said I saw the police footage of
the house and he's like I can't climb
that wall he's like you know what I mean
he's like it would have been impossible
um you know and he's like they're
sitting there going yeah you did climb
that wall and he's just like I didn't
climb that [__] wall but see the
thing about it was that he
they kept him in custody so long like I
said they kept him awake for three days
straight they didn't give him any food
they just kicked the [__] out of him
they tortured him essentially until
finally he just gave up and said fine I
did it so they do actually have and they
saw this I saw this on the documentary
too where they had you know footage of
him and he was only 22 at the time he
had like pimples and everything like
that poor guy and he um you know comes
out and it's like yeah I was just
um walking home and you know my I had
been at work and people were bullying me
and I was mad and I just passed this
house and I didn't intend to kill
anybody but then I just went in there
and did it and you could tell he was
just kind of like repeating back what
they wanted him to say he just gave up
you know what I mean he didn't know he
said he didn't really know what to do
and he said now like you know in 2020 or
2021 whatever they were interviewing him
for this thing he's like you know I
wasn't very educated I was like really
[__] up I was out of it I didn't know
what to do I didn't have anybody to turn
to because aside from this poor dude
having polio when he was a kid
um also his mom
died in a car accident when he was a
little kid and then his dad was a
gambling addict and abandoned him when
he was little and he ended up having to
go live with like a neighbor who like
put him to work like when he was a
little kid and he was like super super
poor so it's like most of the time he's
like we didn't even like we ate maybe
once a day if we were lucky and that's
like about it and now like he's in his
20s working as a welder and now suddenly
he's a serial killer and it's just like
I'm like this poor [__] dude man
yeah life [__] on him in Korean
Society they're looking at him like yeah
he doesn't have a family no real means
of support he did it he's got to be
something wrong with him
yeah I can understand kind of why the
cops would think that may he's a prime
suspect because he would be unusual by
Korean Society that's an unusual
situation for them so it's gonna they're
gonna they're gonna think poorly of him
that's the way they think yeah which is
fine you know like well it's just kind
of like yeah and then yeah so you know
yeah it's [__] up hopefully they it
hopefully they uh gave him some kind of
compensation
they did yeah all right but yeah we'll
get to that so they figured his name and
everything yeah yeah good we'll get to I
mean it took a while but
um and like I said he seems like a
lovely man
um and you'd think that he'd be pissed
and bitter I [__] would be that's for
sure but um he seems pretty chill well
they didn't send him to [__] say it
Quentin
Korean prison [__] probably full of a
bunch of cream puffs really
[__] doesn't take much to go to [__]
prison in Korea
yeah but I don't know we're not gonna be
real hard in criminals well he well the
thing about it one thing that he said
that well the one thing that he said
that yeah that struck me
I thought this was kind of funny he has
you know when they went in his house he
had like two clocks right next to each
other and he's like oh I always have two
clocks because we weren't allowed to
have clocks in prison if you had a clock
you get punished if they found you with
one and he's like I don't know but um
but he's like but he's like so I always
wanted two hmm
but um
well the thing about it was he was in
prison for you know 20 I think it was 21
years or something like that and he's
like by the time he got out he didn't
have any idea like the world had
completely changed and he just had no
idea like how to do anything and he
didn't have any family or anything like
he had luckily he befriended
um one of his uh prison guards like they
became really close friends and that
dude like helped him out a lot because
he was on the documentary too so they
you know became friends that he helped
the guard know that he didn't do it
well the guard said he's like when the
guy came to prison
he's like you know it's pretty common
you know for everybody people in prisons
to be like oh I didn't do it or anything
but he's like usually they chill out on
that after a while yeah yeah I totally
did that but he's like this guy he's
like just vehemently possesses innocence
the whole entire time and he's like and
I'd never met anybody like that even
though you know I'd been in the business
for like 30 years or whatever
um and he's like and after a while he
he's like I didn't believe him at first
I thought he was just like bullshitting
like all the other ones did but after a
while he's like he he started to know
that that he hadn't done it and the
thing about it too was that he also
befriended this woman who was like a nun
and she worked with uh prisoners yeah
and she said I knew him for six months
and I immediately knew that he didn't
that he couldn't have done what they
said that he did there's like just
there's like Yeah
well yeah that too and it's just that's
so dumb I mean that should have
discounted him like immediately because
like I said if you saw him walk there's
like there's no way I'm like a healthy
person whatever had a hard time climbing
that wall well yeah we just do it
[__] in confidence course in the
[__] basic training in the Army you
gotta [__] Rick take a running
[__] leap just especially when you're
short as my ass and [__] reach up and
just get one hand on it and then hook
the other one in and then pull yourself
up and then you kind of run it with your
feet to get up of it and if there's any
hesitation if you slow down at all you
won't have the momentum
but no I do with polio all bent up you
couldn't do it no there's no way a
healthy [__] 19 year old has a
problem doing it that's what I was just
saying yeah it's like you know much less
a guy who's yeah like I said his legs
are kind of like out like that yeah
so but yeah I don't know and they said
whoever broke into that house had to
have climbed over that wall because that
was the only way he could get in there
so
so here's the thing the poor guy
um you know is essentially tortured into
confessing you know that's about the
long and short of it
and so they're like we got him we did it
we solved it you're welcome
so you know they they put him in jail
however
several months later
there were two more murders of the same
thing
now how does that not exonerate the guy
killer you're gonna love this yeah
you're gonna love this yeah so remember
because I said he was caught he was uh
put in prison for the eighth crime and
remember there were two more after that
yeah
so they put him in jail
and then the 9th and tenth murders
happened
and at this point everybody's freaking
out being like hey um you didn't catch
the killer what the [__] and at this
point the cop said oh no no
um he's still the killer it's just that
he's not the serial killer but he did
kill that little girl in the house it
was a copycat oh they're saying he just
did that one that he just did that one
but then he's not oh but the serial
killer is still out there so that was
like pretty much the only way they could
save face yeah was just by saying oh
well he's still a killer we didn't [__]
up we promise son of a [__] and they
did this [__] in a [__] country with
a low crime rate yeah [__] [__]
and I mean in this one yeah and I mean
seriously
but um yeah everyone in the documentary
was very very mad at the cops because
they're like they just really whiffed
this one big time
um you know probably on purpose just
because they were being that way but uh
but yeah so it well I mean it was easy
to say that the one that happened inside
the house that maybe that was a
different killer or a copycat because
the mo was different I mean all of the
other women had been attacked you know
out on the road like while they were
getting off the bus or whatever
or outside their house so it was easy to
argue that that was a different dude you
know what I mean but they found out
later that it wasn't it was the same guy
um so yeah so this poor [__]
Yoon he ended up serving more than two
decades in prison so he was in prison
for like 21 years damn now he got
released on parole in 2009 but was still
considered guilty and ended up having to
move to a different village because
everyone's still kind of you know there
was that Paul of yeah of hanging over
him now it does get better later on but
like I said it took a while
meanwhile
in September of 1989
the real killer who we'll find out about
in a little bit uh actually broke into
someone's house uh wearing gloves and
with a bunch of weapons
now uh he didn't hurt anybody this time
the landlord found him and reported him
to the cops and the cops came and
arrested him now in February of 1990 he
got sentenced to uh a year and a half
for robbery and violence so he goes to
prison and at the first trial he filed
an appeal saying oh I wasn't breaking
into that house somebody was chasing me
and I just ran in there to get away from
them yeah is that the lamest [__]
somebody else made me do it is that the
lamest [__] excuse you've ever heard
the monster made me do it right yeah the
guy you're looking for I was being
chased by a Sasquatch you see and this
was the closest house and I didn't mean
for it yeah he's yeah he's saying the
guy you're looking for made me do this
right pretty much but um yeah so this
like I said now this they found out
later was the real killer but um but
yeah they didn't know he was the killer
at this time because this was 1989. so
um they actually he actually did I don't
think that excuse worked but um they
actually did give him a suspended
sentence so he got released in uh April
of 1990.
now remember how I said that they had
gone through like 21 000 sub suspects or
something like that
um I have heard I don't know if this is
true or not but some sources did state
that at least four people that were uh
suspected of the crime at one point or
another
um ended up committing suicide in the
1990s because of the way they had been
treated by the police
because of abuses and things like that
and like I said this was apparently a
very common thing in Korea at the time
uh police brutality that is and um
during this time period as I said there
were lots of I said there was a lot of
news footage of you know protests Mass
protests against the police for beating
the [__] out of people and uh you know
just you know trying to draw attention
to like human rights violations and
things like that
so the case kind of went into stagnation
a little bit after that because like I
said it wasn't solved at the time
um you know that guy was in prison but
you know they they were kind of like oh
he just did the one but they don't know
about the other ones
so when the bong jinho movie memories of
murder came out in 2003 it actually kind
of renewed um interest in the serial uh
murders and also there was another uh
murder that happened in Hawaii seong in
2004 uh like a school girl or she was
like a college student I think that was
murdered and so they thought oh maybe
this is the same killer or something it
wasn't but they thought that it was the
same Killer maybe
and then
um it kind of got renewed interest again
like in 2006 because again the statute
of limitations which Korea had at the
time was going to expire so they're like
well [__] if we were gonna catch this
person we better catch them now because
otherwise after 2006 we won't be able to
convict them so like I said at the time
there was a 15-year statute of
limitations for first degree murder
um in 2007 they actually increased it to
25 years and then in 2015 they lifted it
entirely partially in response to this
particular case but it wasn't
retroactive like you couldn't go back
and say oh well you know what I mean
like but too but they don't have that
anymore they don't have a statute of
limitations on for screen murder anymore
it was lifted in 2015.
so
what ends up happening with this
[__] the real killer whose name
is holy [__] I just forgot what it was
it's Lee Lee Chun J Lee that's the guy's
name
I knew his first name but I couldn't
remember his last name
so that's the real killer they
discovered later on
what ended up happening and how they
kind of how it came about that uh that
He Got Fingered for this stuff or got
caught for this stuff rather because
that sounded kind of dirty
two years after the last uh of the Weiss
young murders uh which was 1991.
Lee's wife he was married uh took off
and left him
so as kind of retaliation for this I
guess in January of 1994
he actually invited his wife's sister so
his sister-in-law who at the time was
18.
over to his house
and then he drugged her raped her and
murdered her
this his wife's sister
so then he hides her body like in this
garage with a tarp over it and then he
goes to his father-in-law's house and
says oh I'll help you look for your
missing daughter even though he had
[__] raped and killed her right
so um interestingly this when they found
the body it was done but like just like
the Weiss young the other way song
victims like um they'd probably he'd
covered her head in a plastic bag and um
and her jeans like so they he used
clothes to you know tie them up and
stuff and he had tied her hands together
with her underwear
and um had tied other parts of what I
was like stockings and things like that
uh so they didn't find her body for two
days
but uh they pretty much suspectedly
immediately so he got arrested
um also he kept walking around town
asking people how long is the sentence
for rape and murder which that seems a
little suspicious so yeah but he did get
arrested in 1984 for the murder of uh
his sister-in-law but like I said they
didn't know that he was the serial
killer at that time because this was
1994.
so um he said at first that he didn't
kill her
but um he tried to pull the police
brutality thing oh they beat the
confession out of me that's what he said
but um you know he did get convicted of
the crime and was sentenced to death and
then in 1995 uh the court went over his
case like they did a review of it and
they reduced his sentence to life in
prison
um with the possibility of Parole in 20
years
now late much later so he was in prison
for murdering his sister-in-law
but then much later
um for whatever reason just in the
documentary they just said it was like
an anonymous tip
that sent him and said hey why don't you
look into this leech on Jay dude like
for the Weiss young serial murders
because the mo of like how he killed the
sister-in-law was kind of similar and it
was only like a couple years after the
last of the Wiseau murders
so they started looking into him and
they took some DNA and they still had
some DNA saved up from the Weiss young
case that they had kept around even
though they didn't really have a way of
analyzing it at the time and they
compared them
and what do you know uh this
motherfucker's DNA matched the DNA in at
least three of the why selling serial
murder cases
so in September of 2019 uh the police
came out and announced to the public
that Lee had been identified as a
suspect in this in the series of murders
um he was identified like I said after
DNA from the underwear of the victims
was like matched with his and like I
said it took a while uh for people to
kind of get over because his blood type
was not B it was O
but they determined that they had
actually mistakenly thought that the
killer had type B blood back in the 80s
you know what I mean so luckily
um when they discovered that this was
the dude that they were looking for all
this time he was already in prison for
the sister-in-law murder he's actually a
prison in uh Busan which you know like
train to Busan that zombie movie which
is very good if you haven't seen it
um so he's already in there
now at first when they asked him about
the serial killing cases he denied that
too
but
um eventually when they presented him
with all of the DNA evidence that they
had said look we found your DNA and a
bunch of the victims
um and then he basically said something
to the cops that was you know I'm
paraphrasing but he said something like
oh you finally found me or something to
that effect
so after that I guess he knew that they
had his number so he came out and
confessed
here's the thing he not only confessed
to killing all 10 of the canonical
hwysong victims he also confessed to
killing four more victims that the cops
didn't know about or that didn't know
were part of the same series because
they were like in a different town
um yeah and the crimes that he committed
that that he uh confessed to like also
included the one that poor Yoon was uh
convicted of
so yeah so three of the crimes had
actually happened in Hawaii song but
hadn't been like considered part of the
same series I guess because they were
different
um and then the other ones happened in
like somewhere else like in another town
but they didn't know that those were
related but yeah so he had actually
confessed to killing 14 people not just
10.
um he also said that he had committed
more than 30 rapes and attempted rapes
so there's that so yeah 14 at least 14
murders at least 30 rapes so great
so in November of 2019 uh the cops came
out and said that they had pretty much
they didn't want to say yeah he
definitely did it but they said we're
pretty sure he was responsible for all
10 of the serial murders as well as four
more that he confessed to that they
didn't know were part of the same series
um they the police at the time
speculated that he was introverted and
had weak self-esteem
but
he really liked being in the military
but then when he got out he was like
bored and frustrated so decided to start
raping and murdering people as one does
this is his hobby I guess I'm fine
um I think it goes back before his time
in the middle maybe yeah we'll talk a
little bit about like a little bit about
hit like his early life and stuff like
that too but I mean they don't know a
lot about his early life to be honest
with you which is that same pattern
doing [__] to animals and [__] dogs
you know what it doesn't really say that
no that's the weird thing about it is
that he seemed to have a fairly normal
yeah maybe not maybe that's what it is
um but yeah they did um you know he did
have a psychiatric evaluation and said
obviously a psychopathic Tendencies uh
unable to empathize with others
um and also getting off on the pain and
suffering of others guarantee he was
killing animals yeah they usually do you
just didn't get caught they usually do
got you a bunch of neighborhood cats and
dogs went up missing around that time
probably yeah
but yeah so um it wasn't until July of
2020 that the police came and
definitively said this is the guy
um he's the one that did the Weiss young
murders like I said not only the 10
canonical ones but also four that they
didn't know were part of the same Series
so 14 murders
um and also uh nine rapes at least in
that area that were part of that same
series that he didn't kill the victims
although he admitted to raping at least
30 people
um now interestingly they did a retrial
um because Yoon the guy that had been uh
convicted he got out on parole in 2009
remember I said the falsely convicted
guy
um but he was still considered guilty
but he was like we have to have a
retrial so I can clear my name basically
and this like made me so sad when I was
watching this on the documentary he's
like all he wanted and his friend said
this too like the prison guard he said
all he wanted was for
um them to come out and publicly say
that he was innocent so that when he
went to heaven he could meet his mom as
an innocent man because his mom was had
died like when he was a kid and I was
like man that is [__] up that's all he
wanted like for them to say he was
innocent
because you know like I said that had
been hanging over his head the whole
time
so so they did um a retrial for the
eighth murder like you know the girl
that was killed in her bed and at this
particular retrial uh lee came forward
and publicly confessed for the first
time yes I did all those serial murders
at which point uh they said to Yoon they
declared him innocent I saw the footage
they had like the footage of the Court
thing and he said I'd declare are you
innocent performance and stuff like that
nobody hugged him and everything like
that so yeah so he was very happy about
that you know obviously so he's like I
can go to heaven and meet my mom now and
yeah and not be a murderer even though
he was never a murderer but you know
what I mean as if they wouldn't know in
heaven right yeah I know but you know
what it is it just made me sad that you
would think that
um so yeah so here's the thing
because of the whole statute of
limitations thing
had Lee the actual killer Lee Chan Jay
had he not already been in prison for
something else for killing his
sister-in-law
um even if they had no even if they had
the DNA and they knew that he did it and
stuff they wouldn't have been able to
try him for those murders because the
statute of limitations had run out so
we're just kind of lucky well I don't
want to say lucky we're lucky that he
killed somebody else like later on and
they caught him for that like
immediately bye luck by luck yeah not
luckily for her obviously but um so he's
already in prison like serving a life
sentence for something else so he's not
running around loose on the street
it's just that he would have been if he
hadn't what made him confess to the one
murder of the little girl that to free
the uh the other guy
because uh a real sadistic serial killer
wouldn't have done that so I didn't do
that one and left that one out there
well so well the thing about it yeah now
one of the guys there was like a
criminologist or investigator or
something like that that was on the
documentary and he said he thought that
leech on Jay was mad that somebody else
was getting credit for one of his crimes
okay he's doing a BTK yeah maybe I was
like well you think if he was really mad
he would have con like confessed a long
time ago but maybe not
BTK was was what I think well if you go
back and look at the at the btkk Charles
Raider case
he was mad that he was being neglected
that he never became even a suspect
because he wanted the attention yeah
well that's why he started sending
letters he started sending letters back
to him hey you guys for years and years
later you guys must have forgot about me
you forgot about the [__] that I did man
how cool I am I mean you forgot I'm not
even getting any credit out of this [__]
yeah [__] it
which is that's the ego it is yeah and
like I said you should read that book
it's it'll blow your mind yeah it'll
blow your mind yeah like the weird
[__] the weird thought process the
processes that dude has yeah and it's
like that I mean it's just I think the
weirdest thing about it to me was that
he was just like so matter of fact like
it never really occurred to him that
other people might think it was strange
and he thought he was on the same side
as the police yeah you know we're the
same we're in the same business crime
yeah yeah we're working together me and
you yeah that's the way that's the way
he did he genuinely did see it that way
yeah I'm a dog catcher now make sure
your grass is cut you know we're we're
symbols of authority you know yeah we're
authority figures yeah you had your [__]
I got my [__] we're working together to
solve this case together I'm gonna get
I'm gonna give you guys the information
and then I'm gonna get famous that just
[__] nuts [__] man
Camp guy said his Raiders still alive
yeah yes yeah yes he is
as far as I know he's still alive right
he's probably tutoring inmates or
something
teaching them can you imagine how
[__] insufferable yeah that's me he's
just amazing probably giving classes and
[__] he's Dennis explaining yeah well
he's probably like copper you get your
GED
yeah it's probably [__] like that
can you imagine
from BTK teach him a grammar yeah
Jesus Christ I'd rather be dumb you know
let's probably do something like that
[Laughter]
but yeah it's that so but that's what
that got one guy thought he thought that
um that that was why he confessed to all
the murders like at that retrial where
the um where Yoon was because he was mad
that that good guy had gotten like
credit for one of his murders or
whatever
so here's an interesting thing about Lee
chenjae the real why someone serial
killer
and maybe a reason that they didn't look
into him all that closely because the
thing about it was that um he was
actually looked at as a suspect back
then but that's not really saying much
because a lot of people were like I said
it was a small area and they were kind
of running through everybody you know I
mean like they were um you know
investigating everybody like all the men
in the area because why wouldn't you
there's not that many of them but you
know he just kind of passed them by the
thing about it though is that I think
all of the victims lived like pretty
near his house so he was kind of like
right in the middle of like where all
the victim sites were yeah they didn't
they didn't [__] stick pins in the
maps and go where are see I think the
way that they were the way that they
were talking about it like on this
documentary they said look the the
Korean like in the late 80s their
investigative techniques were just not
all that they were just shitty great you
know what I mean like they they didn't
real they weren't real up on Forensic
Science like I said they relied almost
entirely on confessions and they didn't
really have a lot of they didn't they
did blood typing and [__] like that but
but they didn't have the capacity to do
DNA and some and I know DNA was kind of
still in its infancy even here like [__]
all you had to do is just take a map and
put pins or all those bodies were found
and I bet you he lives
well yeah that's like geographical
profile yeah which I always find was
like really fascinating yeah I always
kind of wanted to go into that like get
into that because I think that's really
interesting they can almost always like
figure out where the [__] lives
like where from where the victim yeah
and there's gonna be a traffic flow
through the streets and you're gonna go
he's seeing him coming down this road
he's over here probably seeing him yeah
you know that that's because almost all
of them were like attacked when they got
off a bus yeah like coming home from
work or school or whatever we're certain
roads who's watching yeah had to be like
I said I'm just this was a tiny tiny
Town yeah so I don't really know like
how many roads there were how many buses
there were I don't really know like how
often they ran or anything like that
watching a road and then seeing where
they went yeah following them
but yeah this dude he was born in 1963
interestingly he came from a very
wealthy prominent family hence why he
had soft hands I guess but um damn
[__] well they speculated
somebody speculated on the documentary
they said this might have been the
reason that he wasn't really looked into
with any you know great because they
thought oh well he's a rich guy or he
he's a from a good family so it couldn't
be him like it's got to be some poor
crippled guy that can't even climb a
wall you know what I mean it's got to be
that like a poor person now the
surviving Witnesses
it's just that he said his soft hands
and he's what short
well he was about average height for the
time he was about five six and very
slender and he didn't he didn't cover
his face up he his face was exposed no
apparently not because several people
saw him like a couple like bus drivers
saw him a couple of the victims like
that were raped the saw in his face what
was his demeanor during this
no I don't think any of them really said
like all one of the rape victims said
that he had a low voice but that's about
all she said right walk to oh you stays
too you stays too yeah Shelly it's
probably maybe
yeah weird but the thing about it is
that I mean I've made any threats he
didn't say I don't know I don't know
okay but the thing about it is I mean he
doesn't obviously doesn't look like this
this now because he's older now and he's
like been in prison a while but um when
they showed pictures of him when he was
young well from 1994 when he got
arrested for the sister-in-law murder he
looked very much like the composite
sketch now I mean you know it was a few
years later it was he was I guess he was
30 something when he got arrested for
the sister-in-law murder because I think
he was about 22 or something like that
like when the first yeah yeah which is
what most of the victims said they said
yeah he looked like he was in his early
to mid-20s yeah so yeah he did look very
much like the sketch like when he was
younger
so um so yeah so he did come from like a
quite a prominent family and according
to his family
um you know they said he was very well
educated that he was you know normal he
got along with people he wasn't weird or
anything like that
um and also the one thing that a lot of
uh sources brought up is that he had a
sibling
most sources say sister although a
couple of them said brother it doesn't
really matter but he had a younger
sibling that drowned uh when he was a
kid and that was supposedly some big
trauma or anything like that so yeah so
he graduated from high school in 83 and
joined the army because I think that was
the you did that back then like you did
you serve two years or something like
that Baghdad like yeah
well no the korean's draft or Korea is a
draft Army that's what I'm saying yeah
so yeah that's what you drafted you just
yeah that you just go in like yeah yeah
so he um went in the Army in 83 and was
a tank driver okay and he got out in 86.
and then he worked for like an electric
parts company he works like for in
construction and stuff like that like as
a crane driver and like I said he was
married
um he had a wife he married in 1992.
although according to his wife
um he was a drunk he was an alcoholic
and uh also beat her and their son okay
oh she had a kid too okay so he did have
a family he was doing the murders after
he was married also
um no the murder started in 86 and he
married in 92. so he stopped after he
got he had stopped after he got married
okay well now well okay he well he
killed his sister-in-law after his wife
left him his wife left him after two
years okay like that wife okay yeah all
right he only had one wave okay he
married in 92. all right she left him
two years later because he was he was
abusive drunk and then he killed her
sister okay who was 18. yeah because
they caught him for that okay yeah yeah
that's right they caught him for that
and put him in prison and then heard you
say why because he wanted her
um Revenge I guess I think it was
probably revenge or he couldn't get back
at his wife for whatever reason so he
was just gonna do like the next best
thing or something kill her sister and
kill his sister
who was younger you know what I mean I'm
I'm imagining that's probably what it
was
um like I said I don't know what
happened to the sun like you know poor
kid Jesus Christ
so yeah but he is uh in prison and will
not be getting out
thankfully so there was no um testimony
from him as to why he did this and that
he didn't want to talk about it huh not
really I mean he confessed and you know
said how like why like you know how he
did the stuff and everything but I don't
think he really went too much into it
not that I ever saw
Okay so
um so yeah uh in Korea this is a very
very famous I kind of feel like it's not
as well known over here
but uh over there they've made a [__]
ton of like movies and TV series about
it
um most famous of these obviously is
memories of murder which if you haven't
seen it is excellent um maybe we should
see it I've seen it a couple a couple of
times and I did a review of it but yeah
you'd probably like it actually maybe
they get more into what his motivation
was and what he was thinking well when
they made the movie they didn't know who
the killer was okay all right so the
movie was came out in 2003. okay so it's
got so it's [__] so so yeah it was
based on the case but they didn't know
who the killer was at that time I'd like
to I'd like to hear his side of it of
why he was doing it maybe you could find
an interview with him somewhere like I
said there's not a huge amount in
English about this case it's gonna be
kind of like Charles Raider yeah I feel
like probably or Dennis amazing Dennis
Raider
it's gonna be one of those kinds Yeah
well yeah it's used to be the Korean
version yeah I drove Jack yeah well you
know sometimes you know you got sexual
problems and you know yeah he's gonna be
something like that but yeah yeah but um
they also made well they made a couple
more movies like before uh again before
they knew who the killer was
um there was one called confession or
murder that was from 2012. there was a
TV series called uh Gap dong that was
2014. uh one called signal in 2016. one
called tunnel in 2017. so see there's a
lot
um and then there was another one they
remade signal or there was another one
called signal in 2018 and there's uh
there was also one called taxi driver in
2021 I'm like no not that taxi driver
but there was another one about that
some of them were like more Loosely
based on the case but some of them are
kind of like yeah so like I said
probably one of the most famous serial
killer cases in Korea not that there's a
huge amount but you know we I want to do
a show about that other guy too because
that um that they brought up because he
looked also very interesting you young
Chul that's his name yeah the cannibal
guy run some commercials Jen then we'll
come back well well that was all the um
for the show okay so I don't y'all got
over you didn't get commercials today
well I mean we've been on for two hours
okay all right
and I just wanted to like um
get through all the stuff you know what
I mean yep
um they're talking about the they're
still talking about the um
uh what the what you call them the the
membership things oh the membership
thanks yeah membership thanks yeah I'm
glad you guys enjoyed it
on the Roses of Sanity the smell of
sanctity the smell of sanctity yeah all
right Joe shut it down one day you'll be
purple level like me yeah well did you
have anything else you would like to no
that's what we're talking about yeah
you've been working too hard I got [__]
I gotta do downstairs
okay so that was a problem aren't you
hungry no I just no I just ate all that
lasagna no that's right it was I I
didn't oh okay yeah I just ate lasagna
like a couple hours ago that big huge
piece of it yeah I got a piece of pizza
down there gonna eat oh okay I mean I
wish I had some I should have got some
small Debra's while I was out the small
Dipper's A Little Debbie
I like small Deborah is better I don't I
think the only ones that are left now
are those peanut butter ones and I'm
scared to eat those because they're like
400 calories like five five fifty
big ones you know what I mean it's like
it's like I had like a lip like little
ones no but we don't yeah I don't think
I have like any little chocolates or
snacks or anything like that oh well
um but yeah so I guess it's getting to
be 9 30 and I gotta go to bed soon
because I gotta get up early yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the show this
evening uh thank you all of the people
that joined as members and gave us super
chats and all that kind of stuff uh
always much appreciated especially since
we're starting this new
sad thing yeah and we need some money
for that yeah
to purchase supplies and whatnot what
spending a hundred dollars on dildos and
[__]
oh it's so funny [__] funny I mean we
should like I said we should totally
like on YouTube we could even like do
shows talking about it yeah we're like
giving people advice and stuff like that
yeah we're gonna make some funny videos
got it up we gotta up the entertainment
value the show let's get to get too
stale the money's trying up we just
gotta [__] kick up new business this
is doing it though it'll do it yeah just
wait
[Laughter]
but yeah all right so hopefully you guys
have a good rest of your evening and
have a good day tomorrow and we will be
back on Friday night for our Sidetrack
show so we'll be drinking and talking
about all kind of stuff probably
including 100 dildos well now it wasn't
the one dildo wasn't it was several
buildings yeah
let's show those things on the [__]
show well I don't know if you can
because I was watching one video on that
cam 101 thing where she did like a long
like 30 40 minute video like reviewing
all different sex toys and she was
showing them and talking about them and
stuff like that so some of that [__]
ain't it wasn't pulled off she's a
[__] space Dragon dick I mean I don't
know if you probably can't get it my you
probably can't monetize it yeah right
but she was on like it didn't get pulled
or censored okay she was yeah and she
had all kind of crazy [__] I'm more
interested in the camera that's coming
tomorrow yeah where I'm I'm excited to
try that out I thought oh [__] ride
my motorcycle I'll put that on my
[__] helmet well that's why we wanted
to get a camera like that not just for
this but for other stuff too because
it'll just be good for filming stuff on
the we have a good one we haven't put up
a [__] video of me [__] riding my
[__] Buell [__] Terran tarant acid
through these [__] back roads
so I need to get a video of that yeah
yeah you guys would like it you guys
would ride with me riding with Tom
riding with my [__] custom xb12
my bike's a huge hit at [__] bike
night because there's not many of those
around anymore
okay so oh man look at that thing okay
look I got it Tammy said maybe it's
deemed educational yeah I kind of
figured because it is kind of
educational she's just talking about how
they work and you know if they're any
good uh James Knapp says great case Jen
glad you didn't let Tom Sidetrack you at
all well you know I'll be Edison who
said that James
you did some but yeah at least we kept
it
that's the game that's part we kept it
in about two hours
so you know but yeah everybody thanks
for listening we will see you guys again
on Friday night good night